David Boder: [In English] Spool 126, starting at the eighteenth minute, with an interview with Mr. Isaac Brin, [to interviewee] ja, in English [unintelligible] Issac. Mr. Isaac Brin, Itzhak Brin. Thirty-eight years old, married second time, his wife...second wife is from Palestine, he expects to go over. At the Agudah Israel [unintelligible] of the Agudah in Hénonville, near Paris. Mr. Brin feels that he would not want to tell us a complete story from the Lodzsher Ghetto, but he considers that he wants to pick some special memorial moments.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] דו האסט פארשטאנען וואס איך האב געזאגט. אלזא, הער ברין, זאגט אז [אומהערבאר] גערצײלט טון געשריבן איבער דעם לאדזער געטא. וועט ער זעלבסט דערציילן דאס וואס ער זעלבסט אליין האט געהאט די געלעגנהייט צו וויסן און דורכצומאכן.
Itzhak Brin: [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [In German] Ja. Also, Herr Brin, reden Sie, was Sie wollen. Fangen Sie an. [unverständlich] Kommen Sie näher, bitte. Ja. Sprechen Sie lauter.
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich] Lodzscher Ghetto [unverständlich] Arbeit [unverständlich] Bauabteilung [unverständlich]
David Boder: [inaudible]
Itzhak Brin: am Ende war [unverständlich] für das Ghetto [unverständlich] Ghetto [unverständlich] Wir haben da gelacht und [unverständlich] Frau [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich]
David Boder: ... Ja, wenn sie direkt nebenan [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] verschaffen keine [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, ich hab von [unverständlich] zweispurig [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja. Nun?
David Boder: Ja. Haben Sie gekannt den Doktor Vaug?
Itzhak Brin: Doktor Vaug...
David Boder: Kommen Sie weiter. [unverständlich] letzten Morgen bevor?
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich]
David Boder: A-ha.
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] Ich bin rein gekommen in das [unverständlich] Ghetto, nachdem mir haben zugeteilt ein Wohnung [unverständlich] [unverständlich] die Juden
David Boder: ... Sie waren noch in Rumkowskis Zeiten?
Itzhak Brin: ... Ja. [unverständlich] Rumkowskis Zeit
David Boder: [unverständlich] Was haben Sie gedacht von Rumkowski? [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] Rumkowski... Rumkowski ist gewesen sehr [unverständlich] mit vereinten Kräften. Und alles [unverständlich] abgekriegte von dem Amtsleiter [unverständlich] hatte eine [unverständlich] eine Geheimpolizei [unverständlich] ist gewesen kein Mensch, ist gewesen Ungeheuer [unverständlich] Kartoffeln, hatten wir keine Kartoffeln. Ich bin gegangen zu holen die [unverständlich] Polizei [unverständlich] Auschwitz [unverständlich]
David Boder: Also, [unverständlich] Rumkowski [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] Ghetto [unverständlich] hin, hab ich geholfen, nicht am Ende [unverständlich] Es ist das 44. Jahr [unverständlich]
David Boder: ... [unverständlich] 47. Jahr
Itzhak Brin: ... ´47 [unverständlich] Ich bin gewesen in [unverständlich] am Ende [unverständlich] alle [unverständlich] lieben. [unverständlich] auf der Arbeit. Bauabteilung [unverständlich]
David Boder: ... [unverständlich] Ghetto [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... Doch, doch [unverständlich] die Christen haben mir gegeben [unverständlich]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] hat gegeben [unverständlich] Bäcker. Brot [unverständlich] Wurst [unverständlich] mein [unverständlich] Papier [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja.
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] andere Menschen [unverständlich] solche Sachen. So ein Blödsinn.
David Boder: [unverständlich] aber ich gehe [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] gemacht [unverständlich] euch bei den eigenen [unverständlich] Die Zeitungen [unverständlich]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: ... [unverständlich] gemacht [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] שיסן אין די גאסן [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich]
David Boder: Ja, ja.
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] נישט לײן ײדן [אומהערבאר] צו פאלאלן [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: [In German] ... Und die jüdischen [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] ײן טוג
Itzhak Brin: [In German] [unverständlich] am letzten Tag [unverständlich] Transport ist abgegangen [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] האב איך געזגען [אומהערבאר] א געװיסער ײסלאנדער
David Boder: [In German] [unverständlich] Jiddisch
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] א ײדיש [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] געװיסער ײזמאן, דער ײדישער קאמיטעטסמען
Itzhak Brin: און דער [אומהערבאר]צײטן [אומהערבאר] גאנצע [אומהערבאר] אװעק צום באנהאף [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [In German] Ja. Was hat [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] געטא [אומהערבאר] ײזמאן [אומהערבאר] געשטארבען די טלע [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: [In German] Ist zu [unverständlich] nicht zum [unverständlich] verschikt
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] מײן ברידער [אומהערבאר] דוטע צײטן [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: [In German] [unverständlich] glaub nicht [unverständlich] weiter [unverständlich] ich mit mein Bruder mit meine Schwester [unverständlich] gegangen und [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich] was ist gewesen, geführen [unverständlich] in der Reihe [unverständlich]
David Boder: Das ist Geruch.
Itzhak Brin: Der Geruch. Und [unverständlich] zwei verschiedene Waffen abgestellt mit ... krach machen...
David Boder: Ja. Mit starken [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: Starke [unverständlich] große Graben [unverständlich] gewesen, drei Schiften, eine beim scheiten [unverständlich] doch der Zeit [unverständlich] Menschen [unverständlich] geschossen auch [unverständlich] gegangen [unverständlich] Kranken [unverständlich] Kranken geschossen im Bett [unverständlich]
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] דײטשן, דײטשן
David Boder: [In German] Nun?
Itzhak Brin: [In German] [unverständlich] zusammen hat nicht [unverständlich] keine [unverständlich] Menschen [unverständlich] keine [unverständlich] Mensch [unverständlich] ... [unverständlich] Zeit hat gedauert [unverständlich] Zeit. Doch die Zeit bevor [unverständlich] Arbeit [unverständlich] Das ist die Arbeit und das war im Ghetto der große [unverständlich] dann sind alle Menschen weg [unverständlich] Eisenmann [unverständlich] Abend [unverständlich] und wir sind nur gewesen zehn Mann. Früher sind die Kranken gerufen zehn [unverständlich] zehn [unverständlich] [unverständlich] auf Menschen gibt’s doch einen Punkt für zwei Tage Gestapo [unverständlich] geschickt [unverständlich] Eisenmann zu dem [unverständlich] Ghetto [unverständlich] gesessen [unverständlich] zwei Meter lang.
David Boder: [In English] Eh, this concludes Spool 126 with the report of Mr. Isaac Brin and we are going...about the Lodzsher Ghetto, and we are going over to Spool 127. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording. September 13th, 1946, Hénonville, fifty kilometers from Paris, in the Agudah Israel.
David Boder: Spool 127, continuation of Spool 126. Eh, the interviewee is Mr. Isaac Brin, Itzchack Brin, thirty-eight years old, who was in the liquidation group of the Lodzsher Ghetto.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] אלזא, [אומהערבאר] זאגן מיר [אומהערבאר] געװעזען?
Itzhak Brin: [In German] [unverständlich] einmal [unverständlich] er hat gesagt [unverständlich] machen kein Gericht von [unverständlich] drei [unverständlich] Gruppen
David Boder: [unverständlich] machst du das aus?
Itzhak Brin: [unverständlich] macht sie [unverständlich] gut gedacht zu schießen [unverständlich] Menschen [unverständlich] alle zehn [unverständlich] zehn, drei, vier [unverständlich] ... du gewesen [unverständlich] im sechsten Jahr [unverständlich]
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish]אלזא, עס איז געווען זיבן אינדערפרי, [אומהערבאר] קיין מענטשן אין געטא נישט, אלץ איז שוין געוועזן אויסגעזידלט, איז געקומען צעפארן אן אלטע לאסט אוטא באדעקט, אין יעדע, די מענטשן וואס האבן געזאלט געשאסן ווערן זענען געלעגן אויפן וואגן פון די אוטא אויסגעצויגן, אין די מאנשאפט, די דייטשע געסטאפא [אומהערבאר] מיט דען טאטענקעפ זענען געזיצן [אומהערבאר]. יעדער איינציגער באזונדער איז געוועזן געבינדן די הענט צו הונטן, און מען האט זיי שוין געגראכט, געבראכט האט מען זיי שוין געבונדן, די הענט געבינדן צו הונטן, און דערנאך איז געווען איינער צום צווייטן צוגעבינדן, איינער צום צווייטן, און אזוי די מאנשאפט וואס איז אראפ געגאנגן צום אוטא. הייל, סאלוט, האט מען אנגעהויבן זיי צו שלעפן, און מענטשן זענען נישט געווען ביים קיינע באוואוסזיין, אנגעטון זענען זיי געגאנגן נישט מער [אומהערבאר] אין די גרעסטע קעלטן און בוררות און אפאר הויזן און א העמט, מער גארנישט. דער ערשטער איז אראפגעגאנגן, האט ער מיטגעשלעפט דעם צווייטן, ווייל זיי זענען דאך געווען, די פיס פון הונטן זענען זיי געווען צוזאמען געבינדן. [אומהערבאר] זענען זיי געווען פיר מייל געבינדן, פיר, פיר צו זעקס, פיר פאסיק צו זעקס מאן. צו זעקס מאן זענען זיי געווען געבינדן איינער צום צווייטן. נו, זענען זיי אראפ די ערשטע זעקס, איז געווען איינער א קאפיטאן, האט ער אונז אונז, אונז יידן, מיר זענען געשטאנען אין באדינט, האט ער געהייסן אונז אוועקגיין פופציג מעטער אין א זייט. מיר האבן געהאלטן די ספאדלע [אומהערבאר] אין די האנט. און פון דערווייטנס זענען מיר געשטאנען איז צוגעגאנגן די קאפיטאן מיט א באפעל, [אומהערבאר] מאנשאפט געשטעלט אין א זייט, זעקס מענטשן צוגעגאנגן, די ערשטע זעקס מענטשן צוגעגאנגן נאנט צום גרוב, די גרוב איז געווען אויפגעקאפעט, מיטן פנים צום גרוב, געגעבן איין פייף, א סאלווע, אנידערגעלייגט.
David Boder: א סאלווע פון מאשין [אומהערבאר]?
Itzhak Brin: א סאלװע, סאלװע פון א, פון [אומהערבאר] האנט ביקסן. און אזוי איז געגאנגן די ערשטע זעקס, צווייטע זעקס, דריטע, דריטע פערטע איינער אונטער די צווייטע. ביז מען האט אלע אנידערגעלייגט, האבן מיר אונז באקריגן א פייף, אז מיר זאלן באלד צוקומען, אבער שנעל, איז מען צוגעגאנגן, האט מען געמוזט האבן א מעסערל ביי זיך אין די האנט, אדורכצושניידן איינער פון צווייטן,
David Boder: יא
Itzhak Brin: און, ווייל עס איז נישט געווען מעגלעך מען זאל אלע זעקס מאן קענען אויף איינמאל אריינווארפן. האט מען יעדן אפגעשניטן און יעדע מענטש אנגענומען אזוי ווי
David Boder: אריינגעפאלן אין גרוב?
Itzhak Brin: ניין. אזוי ווי מען האט באקריגט, די ערשטע זעקס זענען געבליבן אזוי הענגן העלפט אין גרוב און העלפט אויף דער ערד. די צווייטע זעקס רייעס זענען דאך געליגן אונטער זיי. די צווייטע זענען נישט געליגן ביים גרוב. ווייל די ערשטע זעקס האבן זיי פארשטעלט. [אומהערבאר] נישט אפגעשניטן איינער פון צווייטן, נישט גלייך געלייגט, נאר די הענט אראפ און פיס ארויף [אומהערבאר] די פון די ערד אפגעקלאפט, אראפאריינגעווארפן אין טיפן גריב אריין, אזוי איינעם אויפן צווייטן, איינער אויפן צווייטן, אבער שנעלער, זענען זיי געשטאנען מיט באטיקעס אין די האנט און אונז געקלאפט, וואס שנעלער, שנעלער. און יעדע לאך פון קאפ איז געווען [אומהערבאר] צו די פויסט פון די האנט?
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] האט מען געשאסן אין קאפ?
Itzhak Brin: געשאסן אין קאפ פון הינטן.
David Boder: [In German] Wie weit sind die Soldaten gestanden von den Menschen?
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] די סאלדאטן זענען געשטאנען אפגעריקט ביז א פיפצן מעטער.
David Boder: [In German] Nu, kann man [unverständlich] immer treffen?
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] מע טרעפט, אלע האט מען געטראפן [אומהערבאר] אזוי איז מען געליגן, אזוי ווי מיר האבן געקריגן דעם פייף אז מען זאל צוגיין, איז צוגעגאנגן איינער, דעם קאפיטאן אליין, און ער האט ארויסגענומען די טאשנרעװאלװער [אומהערבאר] מענטשן וואס האבן זיך גערירט, האט ער זיי [אומהערבאר] די קוילן איבער די קעפ.
David Boder: ווער עס האט גערירט זיך האט ער ציגעשאסן [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: צוגעשאסן.
David Boder: נא.
Itzhak Brin: [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] די מח, די לעבעדיגע האט ער נישט באגראבן?
Itzhak Brin: וואי? און לעבעדיק האט מען קיינעם נישט באגראבן. און די מח, די מוחות האבן זיך צעשפריצט אויף א צען, פופצן מעטער נעבן גריב, און ס’האט געבלוטיגט, און מיר זענען צוגעגאנגן און מען האט עס געמוזט זייער שנעל נעמען די מענטשן און אריינווארפן אין גריב. און די געסטאפא איז געשטאנען דערביי. און מען האט עס
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] מענער און פרויען?
Itzhak Brin: דענסטמאל ביי די ערשטע [אומהערבאר] מאל, איז איין פרוי געווען. די איבריגע איז אלץ געווען מעטער, אין די מיטל יארן. [אומהערבאר] פאלאקן. פאלאקן. פאלאקן פוילישע פאלאקן. נישט קיין יידן. פאלאקן.
David Boder: וואס מען האט געשאסן [אומהערבאר] פאלאקן?
Itzhak Brin: [אומהערבאר] געװיסן פאלאקן
David Boder: דאס זענען געוועזן פאלאקן? מען האט זיי אומגעברענגט אויפן יידישן [אומהערבאר]?
Itzhak Brin: דאס זענען געוועזן פאלאקן. דאס איז געווען די דייטשער, די דייטשער אויפטו. דאס מען זאל נישט וואיסן דאס. האט מען גענומען גוים, פאלאקן, [אומהערבאר] יידישן בית החיים.
David Boder: אה, מען האט געשאסן פאלאקן?
Itzhak Brin: אלעס פאלאקן. ווייל די יידן וואס מען האט דענסטמאל געשאסן, זענען געווען גאנץ ווייניק ווייל יידן האבן זיי געהאט א פארניכטיגונגס קאמף האבן זיי געשיקט ארבעטן אין די קרעמעטאריעס אריין, ווייל די פאלאקן, פאלאקן [אומהערבאר] פאליטיש [אומהערבאר] פאליטישע זאכן [אומהערבאר] וואיסן ווער זיי זענען.
Itzhak Brin: נאכדעם האט מען טיילווייז צוגעשיט אביסל די ערד, האט דאס געהייסן [אומהערבאר] האט ער געהייסן צוזאמענעמען פון ארום און ארום די גריב די מח וואס האט זיך אביסל צעשפריצט, דאס האט איר צו האלטן וועט איר האבן א מיטאג צו עסן.
David Boder: ווער [אומהערבאר]?
Itzhak Brin: די דויטשן האבן אזוי געזאגט, גי געסטאפא. זיי האבן געשפאסט פון אונז. שנעל, שנעל, מאכט דאס. מיר האבן דאס ציגעשיט. ביז אלעס איז געווען פערטיק?
David Boder: [In German] Männer und Frauen [unverständlich]?
Itzhak Brin: Männer und Frauen.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] זאגט מיר, וואס האבן די פאלאקן [אומהערבאר] געטאן? האבן זיי געשריען, געבעטן...וואס האבן זיי געטאן?
Itzhak Brin: זיי האבן געהערט פון דערווייטנס, פון דערווייטנס האט מען געהערט א סך מאל:
Itzhak Brin: [In Polish] O Jezus, o jezus...
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish]נאר צווייטנס, זענען זיי געקימען אין אזא מצב, זיי האבן דאך געוואוסט ווען מען האט זיי געבינדן האבן זיי געוואוסט פארוואס מען בינדט זיי. [אומהערבאר] זיי זענען נישט געווען ביים באוואוסטזיין. טראץ דעם זענען זיי געווען צעשלאגן, אויסגעבלייכט. זיי האבן שוין נישט אויסגעזען. זיי זענען שוין באלד געווען האלב טויטע ווען מען האט זיי געברענגט, אזעלכע באדינגונגען.ביי די זאכן בין איך געווען פינף אדער זעקס מאל, האב איך דאס בייגעוואוינט. די איבערראשונג וואס עס האט געמאכט אויף מיר דאס ערשטע מאל. גאנצע טעג און נעכט בין איך ארום געגאנגן ווי צעדרייט. איך האב עס געמוזט מיט פארציילן [אומהערבאר] אין די לאגער, װי איך בין [אומהערבאר] צוגעטיילט אביסל לאגער האב נישט געטארט פארציילן קיינעם. [אומהערבאר] באריכטן, ווען עס האט זיך געענדיקט די מתים פון יידן, פון די געטא, האט מען אונז אלע ארויסגענומען פון דארטן, און האט אונז געפירט, צוזאמען געלאנטשעט צו די לאגער וואס האט גערוימט די גאנצע לאדזער געטא. דענטסמאלטס זענען מיר געווען פינעף הונדערט מענטשן וואס זענען געבליבן ספעציעל וואס האבן גערוימט די לאדזער געטא.
David Boder: וואס האבן עס גערוימט?
Itzhak Brin: גערוימט. גערייניגט. ארויסגעפירט אלע ווארן. האט מען אונז אפגעטיילט אויך צי די ארבעט. דענמאלס ווען עס איז אויסגעקימען די צייט, און קיין יידישע מאן איז שוין מער נישט געוועזן, און עס איז אויסגעקימען די צייט ווען די געסטאפא האט געברויכט אזא באשטעלונג, האט מען נישט גערופן אנדערע נאר אונז, נאר די צען מאן וואס זענען געווען דענמאלס אויף די צייט וואס מיר זענען געווען אויפן בית עולם. [אומהערבאר] אין לאגער אויך אויסגראבן ווייל קיין אנדערע מענטשן האט די געסטאפא נישט פארלאנגט, נאר עס זאל זיין די זעלבע.
David Boder: א וועלכע זעלבע?
Itzhak Brin: די זעלבע צען מאן וואס האבן געגראבן די טויטע ביי די שאסענען.
David Boder: יא. יא.
Itzhak Brin: [אומהערבאר] לאגער איז מען אויך נאך געוועזן צוויי דריי מאל [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: מיט יידן אדער די פוילן וואס מען האט געשאסן?
Itzhak Brin: מען האט געשאסן נאר פוילן. קיין יידן האט מען נישט געזען שיסן קיינמאל, נאר פוילן. מען זאגט, אלץ איז געווארן געשאסן, [אומהערבאר] אלץ געווען קריסטן. מעגלעך אז, מעגלעך, איין פאקט איז געווען איין מאל וואס עס איז געשאסן געווארן איין דייטש [אומהערבאר] וואס האט געמוזט זיין [אומהערבאר] קריגסוועזן, און דענטסמאל איז מיטגעקימען מיט א סענדזיע, מיט א פראקוראר, אויף די [אומהערבאר] האט מען אויסגעליינט אײן װיראק.
David Boder: האט מען געשאסן דעם איינציגן דייטש?
Itzhak Brin: דעם איינציגן דייטש האט מען געשאסן דארטן. יא, דאס איז איינמאל געווען. דעם איינציגן דייטש האט מען געשאסן אויפן יידישן בית עולם. דענטסמאל האט מען שוין אויסגעליינט אן אורטייל .[אומהערבאר] ביי די פאלאקן איז א פראטאקל גארנישט געוועזן.
David Boder: קיינמאל האט מען נישט געבראכט א גלח?
Itzhak Brin: א גלח. ניין. מען האט נישט געקענט [אומהערבאר] ווער עס איז א גלח און ווער עס איז נישט.
David Boder: א גלח וואס זאל געבן די לעצטע [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: א גלח, ניין
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] געבעט געבן
Itzhak Brin: די געבעט געבן דאס איז קיינמאל נישט געווען. קיינמאל נישט געווען. און דערנאך איז געקימען א פארארדענונג אריין [אומהערבאר] צוגעטיילט פון לאגער, אז מען זאל אויסקאפן אכט גרויסע גריבער אויפן בית עולם. האט מען אויך גענומען
David Boder: וועלכע?
Itzhak Brin: וואי?
David Boder: וועלכע גריבער?
Itzhak Brin: אכט גאנץ גרויסע גריבער.
David Boder: אה, מען זאל מאכן נייע גריבער.
Itzhak Brin: נייע גריבער. האט מען גענומען די אייגענע צען מענטשן וואס מען האט געהאט ביז יעצט אויפן בית עולם און מען האט עס ארויסגענומען. אונז האבן געקאפעט די אכט גרובער. און ס’איז געווען...
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] די גריבער?
Itzhak Brin: ס’איז געווען אזוי ווי מען האט געקאפעט די גריבער האט מען געשטאנען אין פאליטישע לאגער [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: האט מען אייך באוואכט אדער אליין
Itzhak Brin: ניין, דאס איז געקימען דער [אומהערבאר] אײזמאן [אומהערבאר] פארארדענונג [אומהערבאר] צו מאכן זיכער אכט גרויסע גריבער. ארויסקומענדיק פון קאפן, איז געווען איינמאל א פאקט, עס איז ארויסגעקימען דער ביבאװ מיט נאך איין [אומהערבאר] באאמטע פון די געסטאפא, און ער האט געזוגט – איך האב עס אונטערגעהערט. צופעליק. מען וועט לייגן די קעפ דיזע זייטע, די פיס דיזע זייטע און קינדער דעראן, אינדערמיט.צו הונדערט מאן וועט אריינגיין דעראין רואיק. דענסטמאל האבן זיי געהאט, [אומהערבאר] צוגעקימען מענטשן וואס מען האט זיי געפונען באהאלטן, אין לאגער, וואס האבן זיך געהאט אליין ציגעשטעלט. מען האט זיי נישט געהאט גארנישט געטין, ווייל דענסטמאל, די מיינונג פון די דייטשן איז געווען אונז אומצוברענגן און דענסטמאל האט מען געברויכט נאך ארבעטסקרעפטן אין געטא ווייל מען האט געברויכט ווי אמשנעלסטן די געטא אויסרייניגן. [אומהערבאר] האבן זיי אזוי געטראכט וועט מען זיי אויסשיסן, דענסטמאל לאז זיי דערווייל ארבעטן, פאר די אכט הונדערט מענטשן איז געווען אויסגעקאפעט אכט אזעלכע גריבער. שטייענדיק אין קאפענדיק, יעדע שפאדעל ערד וואס מיר האבן ארויסגעווארפן, האבן מיר געזוגט וידוי, ווייל מיר האבן געוואיסט אז די ארבייט, אז די ארבייט, די גריבער איז פאר אונז. עס איז טאקע אזוי געווען, מען האט די גריבער פארטיק געמאכט. [אומהערבאר]. מען האט די גריבער געמוזט מאכן. עס איז טאקע אזוי געווען, מען האט די גריבער פארטיג געמאכט. מען איז צוריקגעגאנגן יעדער צו זייער ארבייטס לאגער.
David Boder: יא. יא. אלזא.
Itzhak Brin: אלזא, זייענדיק אין לאגער, קיין עסן האט אונז נישט געפעלט אין דעם לאגער.
David Boder: אבער וואס האט פאסירט נאכדעם וואס מען האט געמאכט די אכט גריבער?
Itzhak Brin: די אכט גריבער האט מען געמאכט און מען האט געלאזט אפן. מען האט נישט געוואיסט וואס עס וועט זיין.
David Boder: האט איר עס דערציילט פאר די אנדערע מענשטן אין לאגער?
Itzhak Brin: אין לאגער, ווען מען האט געמאכט די אלע אכט גריבער, איז יעדער געגאנגן זייער א שטייגער צעבראכן ווייל מיר האבן געוואיסט אז עס איז פאר אונז. [אומהערבאר] ביי אונז אין ארבעטספלאץ, ביי אונז האט מען יעדן טאג געהאט אן אפעל. [אומהערבאר] דענמאלס האט מען עס געהאט אין ארבעטסלאגער. [אומהערבאר] האט מען אונז, יעדן טאג אינדערפרי האט מען געמאכט אן אפעל.
David Boder: וויפיל מענטשן איז געוועזן?
Itzhak Brin: אכט הונדערט מאן.
David Boder: אהא.
Itzhak Brin: אכט הונדערט, זעקס און זיבעציק מאן
Itzhak Brin: איך בין דארט געוועזן. און מען האט, עס איז געוועזן [אומהערבאר] עס איז געווען ציגעטיילט ארבעט. איך בין געווען ציגעטיילט צו איין ארבעט וואס איך האב געפירט, איבערגענומען די פערד, [אומהערבאר] און נאכדעם ארויספירן.
David Boder: נא?
Itzhak Brin: ארויספירן. [אומהערבאר] האבן נישט געטארט אריינקומען אין געטא. [אומהערבאר] איך האב גענומען זייער פערד און וואגן, אנגעלאדנט די סחורה און ציריקגעפירט און איבערגעבן פאר די קריסטליכע מאן ארויסצופירן פון געטא.
David Boder: אנטשולדיקטס, וואס פאר א ווארע האט מען?
Itzhak Brin: ווארע איז געווען אזוי, מעבל, אייזן, שמאטעס, [אומהערבאר] אלעס וואס האט זיך געפונען אין געטא. איבערהויפט מעדיקאמענטן פארשידענע, עסנווארג וואס איז געבליבן אין געטא. אלעס ארויספירן. אלעס האט מען געמוזט ארויספירן. אלעס האט געמוזט ארויספירן. ווערן אפרייניקן דעם גאנצן געטא. אין נאך יעדע גאס אפרייניקן, נאך יעדע הויז, ווען דאס מעבל איז געווען ארויסגעפירט, דאס אייזן, אין די אלע טעלער, לעפל, שיסל אלץ איז געווארן ארויסגעפירט, האט מען די געטא אריינגעגעריקט אין פלאט אין [אומהערבאר] און אין די הייזער זענען געקימען דייטשן מיט קריסטן, קריסטליכע ארבײטער, פאלאקן, מען האט אויפגעריסן מיט א, מען האט ארויסגענומען דאס האלץ, די בעלקעס, די אלע פאדלאגעס [אומהערבאר] און נאכדעם האט מען דאס הויז [אומהערבאר] איינגעלייגט אינגאנצן. אזוי איז געגאנגן כסדר, כסדר.
David Boder: און וואו האט איר געלעבט? אין באראקן?
Itzhak Brin: אונז האבן [אומהערבאר] געהאט אזא לאגער, א הויז וואס איז געוועזן, אין יענע צייט איז דארטן געוועזן [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: וואי זענט איר געשלאפן דארטן?
Itzhak Brin: געשלאפן אויך דארט אינעם לאגער.
David Boder: אין די בעטן?
Itzhak Brin: בעטן האבן מיר געהאט זייער גוטע, ווייל בעט געוואנט האט נישט געפעלט אין געטא. ווען מען איז אריין, אין וועלכע שטוב האט מען זיך גענומען דעקן קישענעס און מען האט געהאט. עסן האט מען אויך געהאט גוט אין לאגער, ווייל עס איז געבליבן גרויסע מאגאזינען פון עסנווארן וואס איז געוועזן פאר די גאנצע געטא, זיבעציג טויזענט יידן אז עס איז געבליבן עסנווארן, האט מען דאך געקענט אכט הונדערט מענטשן געבן צו עסן געניג. איבערהויפט אז די דייטשן האבן געוואלט אז מען זאל פלייסיק ארבעטן האבן זיי געזאגט, עסן זאלט עטס וויפיל [אומהערבאר], ווייל זיי האבן געוואלט די ארבעט זאל גיין וואס שנעלער.
David Boder: זאגט...
Itzhak Brin: און אזוי האט מען, יעדן טאג אינדערפרי האבן מיר געהאט אזא אפעל, [אומהערבאר] יעדן צוגעטיילט צו די ארבעט. איז געקימען, דאס איז געוועזן דאנערסטאג, דעם זיבעצנטן
Itzhak Brin: [In Polish]...styczeń.
David Boder: [In Yiddish] זיבעצנטן וואס?
Itzhak Brin: זיבעצטן, זיבעצטן יאנואר, יאנואר.
David Boder: פינף און פערציג.
Itzhak Brin: פינף און פערציג יא. האט מען געקימען, האט מען גערופן פון אונז אין לאגער א ייד.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: ניין, ער האט זיך גערופן א געוויסע ברודער. און מען האט אים געזוגט, דאס האט, דאס האט מען אים גערופן אין זיבעצנטן
Itzhak Brin: [In Polish]...styczeń...
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] [אומהערבאר] האט געברויכט זיין אן אפעל. גערופן האט מען אים די זעכצנטן [אומהערבאר] אויפדערנאכט אין געסטאפא אריין, און מען האט אים געזאגט אזוי, מארגן פרי זאלן אלע פון לאגער ביז איינער, ווייל עס איז געווען יעדן טוג צום אפעל, איז געווען פיפציק מאן וואס האבן געדינט, פיפציק פאר פערד, וואס די פערד האבן געארבעט ארויסצופירן די ווארע פון געטא. איז די מאן, די מענטשן זענען נישט געשלאפן אינאיינעם אין לאגער מיט אונז, זיי זענען געשלאפן ביי די שטעלער פון די פערדע. עס זענען געווען ספעציעלע [אומהערבאר] וואס האבן געארבעט טוג און נאכט [אומהערבאר] מיט רעכענונגען, זיי זענען אויך נישט געשלאפן.
David Boder: יידישע?
Itzhak Brin: יידישע. נאר אין דעם טוג נאר דאנערסטאג פרי, די זיבעצנטן אינדערפרי איז געווען א פארארדענונג, אז אלע זאלן זיין, פון קליין ביז גרויס [אומהערבאר] אלע זאלן זיך געפונען אויף דעם אפעל. מיר האבן געוואיסט [אומהערבאר], וואס מען האט געהאט אין געהיים. [אומהערבאר] מיר אז דא גייט מען אונז אלע אויסשיסן. און געוואיסט האט מען אז די גריבער זענען נאך אפן אויפן יידישן בית החיים. אט, איז געגאנגן די לאגער פירער וואס איז געקימען זייער [אומהערבאר], ווייל ער האט אויך דערשפירט אז דאס וואס גייט אונטער אונז, און אויך איז געגאנגן די לאגער פירער און האט איין דײטש אפגעקויפט, א געסטאפא מענטש, ער האט אים געגעבן א גאלדענע זייגער און האט אים אנ’געשיכור’ט. האט ער אים געזוגט, [אומהערבאר] מארגן קענט איר אלע האבן.
David Boder: יא.
Itzhak Brin: די לאגער פירער איז געקומען אין זעכצנטן יאנואר ביינאכט. איז ארויפגעקימען אין לאגער. “קינדער, זאגט ער, יידן, ראטעווען זיך, יעדער איינער וואס קען.” איך, [אומהערבאר] דארט איז געווען פלאץ אויף אכט מענטשן, און מיר זענען געגאנגן און מען האט אריינגענומען, מען האט מיטגענומען מיט זיך באקאנטע נאך, ביז צוואנציג מאן און ווייל מיר האבן געוואיסט אז דארטן לאנג וועט מען נישט זיין, ווייל מען האט געוואיסט אז די רוסן זענען שוין אין טשענסטאכאװא, זענען מיר געגאנגן אין בונקער אריין, און מען האט אונז דארטן באהאלטן.
David Boder: ווי האט די בונקער אויסגעזען? דערציילט מיר, וואו האט מען עס געמאכט אין דעם בונקער?
Itzhak Brin: די בונקער איז געווען, אזוי ווי אייך האב געארבעט, [אומהערבאר] ביי די ארבייט האב איך מיך, האב איך מיך אויסגעלערנט [אומהערבאר] עס איז געווען הינטן איז געוועזן געמאכט אן ערשט-קלאסיקע שטוב פון פיר מעטער אויף צווײ, פיר מעטער אויף דריי איז די שטוב גרויס געווען.
David Boder: וואי? איז עס געווען אויף די ערשטע שטאק? אדער אין קעלער אריין?
Itzhak Brin: שטאק. טיף אראפצוגיין, אראפצוגיין דארט, אין קעלער. אראפצוגיין אין א קעלער אריין. אין אינמיטן גאלאפן, אין די הייעך פארדעקט מיט דארנס גרוז [אומהערבאר] צווייגן, איז געווען אויסגעקאפעט א גריב און געצויגן איז געווען, וואסער איז געווען געצויגן [אומהערבאר] איז געשטאנען, איז געגאנגן רעגן וואסער פון דער ינען. עס איז געווארן געמאכט אזא, צוגעצויגן דערינען פון אונטער די ערד, אזא קאנאפיע, אז די וואסער פון די רעגן זאל אריינגיין אין די פעסער אריין, צום טרינקן. אויף די הייעך איז געלעגן א שטיקל ווארע סחורה, און עס האט דורכגערייניקט.
David Boder: פילטרירט.
Itzhak Brin: פילטרירט. און דארט איז געשטאנען וואסער [אומהערבאר] ווען עס האט גערעגנט.
David Boder: נא?
Itzhak Brin: דארטן איז געוועזן [אומהערבאר] עס איז געווען גאנץ גוט אויסגעשטעלט.
David Boder: ווען די וואסער גייט אריין, ווער קען עס פארדעקן?
Itzhak Brin: עס איז געווען צו מאכן אינעווייניק מיט א הענטל, אזוי אויסצונעמען, צו פארריקן. עס איז נישט געווען אזוי געפערלעך. [אומהערבאר] און ווען מיר זענען הינטן געוועזן. ווען מיר זענען אראפגעגאנגן, איז געגאנגן איין און צוואנציק מאן ארויס. טייל מענטשן, [אומהערבאר] ווען מיר זענען אוועקגעגאנגן דארט, עס איז געווען די אכצענטן ביינאכט. מיר זענען געזעצן אין זיבעצענטן [אומהערבאר] אין בונקער. אין אויף די אכצענטן [In Polish] styczeń. [In Yiddish] אינדערפרי, הערט מען וואס אויף די ערד, מען גייט, עס קלאפט אויס א ווידערקול, מען גייט, מען גייט. און דארטן, ווייסט מען, דארטן ווייסט מען האט א מענטשלעכע פיס נישט געטרעטן. האט מען פארשטאנען אז דא [אומהערבאר] איז מען געגאנגן, און מען האט איינעם ארויסגעשיקט, איינער האט זיך ריזיקירט און א גיי ארויסגעגאנגן, האט ער געזען ווי פאלאקן זענען אריינגעקומען שוין, און די דראנטן פון די געטא זענען שוין צעריסן, און די פאלאקן לויפן אריין און זוכן אין די שטובער יידישע זאכן, מען ראבירט יידישע זאכן, און אונז האט מען דאך געזען, מיר זענען געגאנגן די, די...
David Boder: מיט די לאטעס
Itzhak Brin: מיט די לאטעס, “אוי, א ייד”, און מען איז ארויפגעפאלן אויף אונז, און מען האט אונז צעקישט
David Boder: די פאלאקן?
Itzhak Brin: די פאלאקן [אומהערבאר] און מען האט געזאגט, אוי, די רוסן זענען דא. דער וואס האט געהאט ארויסגעגאנגן איז אראפגעקומען מיט א געוואלד, מיט א שמחה, “קינדער, מיר זענען געהאלפן.” די רוסן זענען דא, זאגט ער. מען איז געגאנגן, מען איז ארויס געגאנגן אין גאס אריין, איז מען אהין געגאנגן דארטן אין לאגער, האט איז געוואר געווארן אזוי: אז טאקע דעם דאנערשטאג אינדערפרי, דאס מיינט די זיבעצנטן [אומהערבאר] אינדערפרי איז געוועזן, איז געקומען ביז קנאפע צוויי הונדערט מאן, געסטאפאװציס, מיט געווער אין די האנט. זיי האבן ארומגענומען דעם גאנצן לאגער, [אומהערבאר] און אין לאגער הויפן, און זיי האבן געשריגן, יידן ארונטער. איז געבליבן אפאר עלטערע מענטשן, מיט אפאר קראנקע, וואס איז אראפגעגאנגן, האט מען גענומען א טייל פון זיי האט די פאליציי גענומען מען האט זיי אהינגעפירט [אומהערבאר] אין די קרימינאל פאליציי. און די איבריקע געסטאפא האט זיך געלאזט אין דעם גאנצן געטא זוכן מענטשן. ווייל עס איז קיינער נישט געבליבן. עס איז געבליבן א טייל האבן זיך פארשטעקט.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: און געבליבן, איז האבן זיי צוזאמען גענומען [אומהערבאר] פון זעכציק מאן. און אינמיטן זוכן, עס איז געווען דאנערשטיק, זיבעצנטן יאנואר, צוויי [אומהערבאר] האבן זיי באקומען א פארארדענונג, דאס זיי מוזן אוועקגיין, האבן זיי געהאט, איז די מענטשן וואס זענען געבליבן פארשלאסן אין די קרימינאל פאליציי, זענען אויך געבליבן לעבן, און צוויי טעג אינדערפרי האבן זיי די פאלאקן געעפנט די טירן און זיי ארויסגעלאזט [אומהערבאר] קיין קיין מענטש, אלע זענען געבליבן און זיי האבן זיך אלע גערעטעט.
David Boder: יא. אלזא, און די פאלאקן האבן פאר אייך קיינמאל קיין אנטיסעמיזם נישט געצייגט?
Itzhak Brin: זיי האבן קיינמאל נישט קיין אנטיסעמיזם פאר אונז געצייגט. זיי האבן געהאט, זיי האבן נאך מורא געהאט פאר אונז. אונז האבן דאך געזען ווי זיי ראבירן די יידישע האב און גוטס. נאר [אומהערבאר] וואס געפונט זיך אין א שטיב. די גאנצע צייט וואס מיר האבן געארבעט אין געטא האבן מיר געטרעטן אויף די טייערסטע זאכן. וואי מען האט געזען, דאס האבן מיר יא געטון, וואו מען האט געזען א טייערע זאך. מען האט געזען א טייערע [אומהערבאר] מאנטל, מען האט געזען א טייער [אומהערבאר] אז די דייטשן זאלן קיין גענוס נישט האבן דערפון, האט מען געפאקט איינעם, האט מען באקומען גיט געשלאגן דערפאר. מיינסטענסטייל, וואס מען האט יא ארויסגעשיקט, האט מען אלעס געמאכט א טל דערפון פריער, זיי זאלן קיין גענוס נישט האבן דערפון.
David Boder: אהא. נא, זאגט מיר דאס. ווי אזוי זענט איר געקומען קיין פראנקרייך?
Itzhak Brin: יעצט קיין פראנקרייך? יעצט בין איך געפארן קיין פוילן הייסט עס. בין איך געפארן קיין לאדז, איך האב זיי געהייראט מיין צווייטע פרוי פון מיין שטאט. זי שטאמט פון פון שעראדז.
David Boder: פון וואו?
Itzhak Brin: פון שעראדז. נעבן לאדז.
David Boder: יא.
Itzhak Brin: און מיר זענען געזעצן אין לאדז. איך האב זיך געהאט געפירט איין מסחר פון [אומהערבאר] אין די שטאט שעראדז, האב איך געקענט קריסטן פון [אומהערבאר] איך האב געפירט מעיל קיין לאדז. [אומהערבאר] קיין לאדז. די מצב פון אנטיסעמיזם האט זיך געשטארקט אין פוילן, דאס איך האב געמוזט יעדע וואך, צוויי, דריי מאל פארן אין שטאט אריין מיט געלט. אין זיך בארעכענען [אומהערבאר] וועגן מסחר.
David Boder: מיט וועם בארעכענען?
Itzhak Brin: בארעכענען זיך מיט דעם [אומהערבאר] עס איז שוין געווען זייער קאמפליצירט, צוליב דעם וואס עס איז שוין געוועזן איין פאקט אויפן וועג וואס מען האט אפגעשטעלט מען האט געזוכט יידן, עס איז געווען זייער קאמפליפיצירט. האב איך געמוזט עס ליקווידירן. און פארשאפט מיר איין פאס, און אהערגעפארן אויף פראנקרייך. מיין פרוי, [אומהערבאר] אן אדוואקאט דורך מיינס א ברודער וואס געפינט אין ארץ ישראל [אומהערבאר] אדוואקאט. און איך בין געבליבן [אומהערבאר] אוועקפארן מיט עלי’ ב’ דערווייל [אומהערבאר] אין ארץ ישראל, זיך שטארק פארענדערט, בין איך געבליבן דערווייל דאהי אין קיבוץ. און איך האף מיט ג-טליכע הילף וועל איך ווערן פאראייניגן מיט מיין פרוי [אומהערבאר]
David Boder: זייער וויכטיגע זאכן האט איר מיר דערציילט. איך האב שוין [אומהערבאר] אזא דערציילונגען פון לאדזער געטא, אבער עס האט מיר קיינער נישט דערציילט וואס איר האט מיר פארציילט. ספעציעל די גאנצע זאך פון די געשיכטע פון די ווארע, [אומהערבאר] אויסרייניקן די געטא, מען זאל עס ליקווידירן, ארויסנעמען די טויטע, ווייל די דייטשע האבן נאך גענומען די לעצטע מאמענט אלע זאכן.
Itzhak Brin: אלעס.
David Boder: [In German] Danke sehr...
David Boder: [In English]...This concludes the interview...eh?
Itzhak Brin: [In Yiddish] איך וועל אייך דערציילן נאך איין עפיזאד פון מיין שטאט שעראדז.
David Boder: יא. איר האט די מייקראפאן אין אייער הענט.
Itzhak Brin: איך וועל אייך איבערגעבן אן עפיזאד וואס איך האב דאס אויך בייגעוואוינט זייענדיק [אומהערבאר] אנפאנג קריג, ווען די דויטשן זענען אריינגעקומען אין די שטאט שעראדז, דאס איז אכציק קילאמעטער פון לאדז, וואס מיר האבן מיטגעמאכט דארטן. פארן אנפאנג קריג, ווען די דויטשן זענען שוין געווען אין אונזער שטאט, איז גייענדיק אין גאס, אין שעראדז איז אנשטאנען אן אוטא אינמיטן מארק. אין די פאליציי האט געמאכט א, א...
David Boder: אן אבלאווע
Itzhak Brin: אן אבלאווע. און מען האט געכאפט [אומהערבאר] און מען האט גענומען צוואנציק יונגע מענטשן און מען האט זיי ארויפגעכאפט אויף דעם אוטא. איך בין גראדע אויך געווען אינצווישן מען האט אונז א כאפ געגעבן אויפן אוטא און מען איז אוועקגעפארן מיט אונז. וואו אהין מען פארט האט מען נישט געוויסט, נישט געוויסט וואו אהין מען פארט. און שטאט האט זיך באלד געמאכט א גרויסע גערודער. מען האט נישט געוויסט וואס עס קומט פאר. איז מען געפארן.
David Boder: ער דערציילט דעם עפיזאד, נאך איין.
Itzhak Brin: אזוי מען האט אונז געכאפט האט מען אונז געפירט נישט ווייט, איין קילאמעטער אינטער די שטאט, דאס איז אונזער יידישער בית עולם אין שעראדז, און מען האט אונז ארויסגעפירט, און מען האט אונז געזוגט, מען זאל קאפען דא א גריב. אונז האבן געקאפעט דאס גריב זייער שנעל. מען איז געשטאנען, און מען האט אונז געיוגט ביי די ארבייט. קאפענדיק האבן אונז געוויינט מיט טרערן, מיר האבן נישט געוויסט פאר וועמען מען קאפעט און מיר האבן געמיינט זיכער אז מען גייט אונז דא אלע אויסשיסן. דאס גריב איז פאר אונז. דאס גריב איז געמאכט געווארן האט מען אונז אלע נעם געגעבן, אין די אוטא איז צוריקגעפארן צוריק אין די שטאט אריין, האט מען אונז אלע א נעם געגעבן, און מען האט אונז אלע געהייסן אוועקגיין פון גריב, און מען האט אונז אלע געהייסן זיך צושטעלן צום מויער, מיט די הענט אין די הייעך און מיטן פנים צי די מויער. די מויער הייסט עס, די מויער פון דעם בית החיים, די פלאט. אזוי שטייענדיק, האט מען אונז געציפעט, געזאגט וידוי. אונז האבן געמיינט זיכער מען גייט אונז אויסשיסן. דערווייל איז מען געבליבן אזוי שטיין, אינמיטן זעהט מען ווי אן אוטא קומט אן צופארן, הונדערט מעטער אפגעריקט פון די יידישע בית עולם, דארט איז געשטאנען א מלין.
David Boder: א וואס?
Itzhak Brin: א מיל. א פאראװי מיל. און זיי האבן אראפגעשטיפט מענטשן פון די אוטא. די אוטא איז געבליבן שטיין צוריקגעפארן אין שטאט אריין. און די דויטשן וואס האבן באוואכט די מענטשן האבן זיי גענומען און האבן זיי געשלאגן מיט די קאלבעס, מיט די הענט אין די הייעך, האבן זיי געשריגן, לויפן, לויפן, לויפן, שנעל, שנעל, שנעל.
David Boder: וויפיל מענטשן זענען געווען דארט?
Itzhak Brin: עס זענען געוועזן דריי און צוואנציק מאן. עס איז געוועזן די היטער פון די שטאט שעראדז סענדזיעס, אדוואקאטן, פראקורארן, [אומהערבאר] קריסטן. עס איז געוועזן איין יידישע ארצט א געוויסע עליאס [אומהערבאר] אן אויגן דאקטער, א געוויסע פראפעסער. נאך איין תאוטעכויק, א געוויסע ראזענקראנץ, שראליק ראזענקראנץ, און די מענטשן האט מען אזוי צוגעיוגט, ביז צום, זיי זענען געוועזן, געזעצן אלץ זאקלאדניקיס
David Boder: [אומהערבאר] זאלאזשניקי
Itzhak Brin: זאלאזשניקי אין תפיסה. [אומהערבאר].
David Boder: יא.
Itzhak Brin: דיזע מענטשן האט מען געפירט, מען האט זיי געהייסן לויפן, לויפן, ביז זיי זענען צוגעקימען צום הויז פון דעם אריינגאנג פון דעם בית החיים, פון בית עולם. פלוצלונג דערזען זיי [אומהערבאר] געווארן אביסל לייכטער. און מען האט געזען אז געוויס, געווענלעך וועט מען שיסן די מענטשן.
Itzhak Brin: פלוצלונג, שטייענדיק נאך מיט די הענט אין די הייעך ביי די מויער, האט מען געזען די מענטשן קומען ארויס, הא, הא, געעטעמט שטארק פון די לויפנס זיי מיד צו מאכן. און מען האט זיי די אלע מענטשן ארומגיין, אויסמיידענדיק אז זיי זאלן נישט זען דאס גריב, גענומען זיי פון אן אנדערע ווינקל אריין פון דעם בית עולם. דערנאך האט מען גענומען פון אונז, פון די דריי-צוואנציק מענטשן האט מען ארויסגענומען זיבן מאן וואס מען האט זיי צוגעשטעלט צום גריב. מען האט זיי געהייסן מאכן
David Boder: זענט איר געווען פון די זיבן מאן?
Itzhak Brin: ניין, פון די זיבן מאן בין איך נישט געווען. אבער די איבריקע זענען מיר געבליבן שטיין מיט די הענט אין די הייעך ביי די מויער. און די זיבן מאן זענען צוגעגאנגן. מען האט זיי געהייסן מאכן א בערגל ערד הארט ביים גריב. א בערגל ערד ביים גריב. דאס זענען געווען מיינע קאלעגן אויך, געווענלעך האבן ער מיר דערציילט ווי אזוי עס איז צוגאנגן. אונז האבן מיר געמוזט שטיין איבערגעדרייט מיט די הענט אין די הייעך, געדרייעט צום מויער. האט מען גענומען, מען האט געברענגט יעדן איינצעלנעם פערזאן אהין און מען האט אים געהייסן מיט די קניען, אויף דעם בערגל אראפלייגן דעם קאפ און איין מאן איז געשטאנען מיט א טאשן רעוואלווער אין מען האט געשאסן, אזוי ווי מען האט געהערט דעם קויל, האבן שוין געמוזט צולויפן אונזערע מענטשן, די זיבן מאן, א נעם געבן, אריינלייגן אין גריב אריין. אזוי האט מען געפירט איינער אונטער דעם צווייטן. איינעם אונטער דעם צווייטן. ווען מען איז ציגעקימען, איינער האט געהייסן דארט איינער, יעקבי ראזען, דער איינער לעבט שוין נישט היינט. אין אוישוויץ אהינגעקומען. האט ער מיר פארציילט, ווען מען איז צוגעקימען צו דעם ייד ישראליק ראזענקראנץ, דעם טעכניק, האט ער ווען ער האט געקריגן דעם קויל האט ער אים א נעם געגעבן פון בערגל אראפ אריין אין גריב אריין, [אומהערבאר] האט ער א זאג געגעבן, יעקב’ל וואס טוסטו, איך לעב דאך נאך! ער האט אים געקענט יעקב ראזען. וואס טוסטו, איך לעב דאך נאך. אזוי איז מען געגאנגן און מען האט איינער אויפן צווייטן כסדר, איינער אויפן צווייטן געשאסן. און מען האט זיי באגראבן אין די [אומהערבאר] אין די אנגעטואכץ. ווי אזוי זיי זענען געגאנגן אנגעטון. די היסטערישע געוואלדן פון די מענטשן איז אומבאשרייבלעך.
David Boder: [אומהערבאר]
Itzhak Brin: די וואס מען האט זיי געשאסן, צוגייענדיק צום גריב.
David Boder: זיי האבן געשריען?
Itzhak Brin: זיי האבן געשריען. אזוי [אומהערבאר]. מען האט זיי אלע געשאסן.
David Boder: אלע מענער?
Itzhak Brin: אלע מענער. די יידן צוויי, אויך פון אונטער דערצווישן [זיי]. און מען האט זיי אלע געשאסן, און מען האט זיי אלע אזוי באגראבן. און יעצט איז געווארן מיט א יאר צוריק איז געווארן געמאכט א עקסכומאציע [אומהערבאר] וואס מען האט זיי ארויסגענומען פון יידישן בית החיים און מען האט זיי אריבערגעפירט אויפן פוילישן צמענטאזד. און אויך, נאכ’ן אפטון די שטיקל ארבעט, האט מען גענומען די אלע צוואנציק מאן, ארויסגעפירט דורך די פאליציי. מען האט זיך געמוזט אונטערשרייבן אז די זאך וועט נישט ארויסקימען. ווער עס וועט פארציילן וואס עס איז געווען דא [אומהערבאר] צווישן די יידן, וואס עס איז דא פארגעקימען, זאל וויסן אז ער וועט געשאסן ווערן. וואס אין אמת’ן, די אלע צוואנציק מענטשן זענען זיך גראד צולאפן אין שטעטלעך ארום, זיי האבן נישט געוואלט בלייבן דארטן, ווייל זיי האבן מורא געהאט טאמער מען וועט זיי באשולדיקן דערפאר. זענען זיי זיך צעלאפן. איינער איז געלאפן דא. איינער איז געלאפן דארט.
David Boder: אין געטא אוועקגעלאפן.
Itzhak Brin: אין געטא אריינגעלאפן.
David Boder: אלזא. הער ברין, איך דאנק אייך זייער. דאס איז טרויעריקע געשיכטן. מען קען נישט זאגן אז דאס איז א גוטע געשיכטע אבער עס איז א וויכטיגע געשיכטן, איינפאך פארציילט, פון א מענטש וואס האט מייסטנס געזען, און איך דענק אז דאס וועט זייער ניצלעך זיין. איך דאנק אייך זייער.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mr. Isaac Brin [unintelligible]...eh, Mr. Isaac Brin. At Hénonville. He apparently worked a special...hm, especially in a very gruesome type of work. He did not want to tell his whole story, but we got from him nearly one and a half spools. Hénonville near Paris, September the 13th, 1946. Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.
David Boder: [break in wire]...six...Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.